some people call them is some people
call them Isis some people call them
ISIL a 16 year old schoolboy told the
Daily Mail that he saw Islamic state
fighters playing soccer with a severed
human head inside the Yarmouk refugee
camp located just six miles outside the
Syrian capital Damascus in December 2012
civil unrest transform your moves from a
thriving district into a combat zone for
anti and pro-government armies before
your mooks takeover by Isis in April
close to 18 thousand refugees had been
residing there only about 2,500 of them
or 500 families managed to escape in
just a week that Jerris group has killed
around 200 people all right so the
Yarmouk refugee camp it's been a
disaster for a long time they've
basically been keeping Palestinians in
there giving them virtually no rights
the Syrian government gives them pretty
much nothing and now Isis is rampaging
through there every time we do an Isis
story at this point between the headings
and burning people alive do you get
outraged anymore or do you even not even
outraged like I see this and it's just
like you see it on Twitter going buying
up soccer with the human head up another
like how desensitized to this stuff are
you in general anybody else but I'm
definitely not desensitized but it is
unfortunately not shocking anymore
yeah I'm not desensitized to the horror
of what this is so I mean it gave me
chills listening to that story again but
it's still one of those things where
you're like kind of think they would do
something that abhorrent like think of
the worst possible thing they're
probably yeah Isis dude no no by the way
there's also history sadly there's
history of guys doing this with heads al
Qaeda was doing it a couple years ago
where's your dissent we've talked to
Isis a lot when I've had you on where's
your desensitization level at these days
every time I read something like this I
have the same like got like sickness
feeling reaction I was reading that
article and there was a part where they
said that they were cutting children's
heads off in front of their parents like
I mean that's a kind of thing that just
makes you sick yeah they have kids
literally doing the beheadings now too
like what you said like you think of the
worst possible thing and they're
probably doing it so
you know it's it's already been clearly
established that Isis does not view with
the people who they do these things to
as human like they just they have no
moral sense for that at all
so whenever they do these things it's
like they're doing it to an inanimate
object like they just do not care so
what do you guys think they're ending
this because we never talked about this
in the media we talked about well should
we bomb them should we how horrible it
is etc it said but what's the hanging
they can't behead everybody you can't
keep every woman covered head to toe
just with the solicitor eyes I mean what
do you think the end is all together
because I think that's too much like
that's way too much flash I don't know
because I can't I can't put my mind in
that kind of mindset yeah
is that part of it though we can't
exactly stand yeah them what the hell is
what are you doing like where is this
how is this going to end
yeah and but my for me it comes back
back to what are we waiting on like
clearly these are like kind of animals
let's just call a spade a spade
so what should we do what do you think
because we've talked about this before
and I always say I'm not for
intervention in general we've [ __ ] up
so much in the Middle East look at Iraq
now it's basically not a country anymore
Syria's pretty much not a country by all
standards so I'm not really for
intervention and yet we're watching some
truly horrific stuff happen if we could
have jumped in and stopped the Nazis
earlier if Twitter had existed back then
a YouTube and we would have seen what
was going on you know even in seen
footage of crematoriums River we
probably would have jumped in earlier
and we would have saved millions alive
so isn't it sort of incumbent on us to
do something I would like to do
something but at what point are you
crossing a line and and you know putting
yourself at risk or causing problems and
like I mean we already have a bad
reputation as the United States of going
places where we shouldn't be going and
staying in other countries for too long
but at the same time like you see
horrible things like this when you want
to jump in and help so even like myself
like I have a hard time like balancing
that in my own mind like oh I want to
help them well United States is
intervening all the time where they
shouldn't be or okay I don't want to
help them what are you doing so it's
it's very so I think pretty much
everyone in the country feels that way I
think that's what it is we're watching
something horrible people are thinking
what you're saying what are we waiting
for and then the rest of the
half of the other the other half of the
brain is going well we can always [ __ ]
it up so it's gonna get worse but what
do you do with that you have to do
something though because I think that
whether or not Monroe Doctrine or
manifest destiny or whatever the United
States is a superpower we have the
ability to do so much more and yes we
[ __ ] up in the past we have [ __ ] up
in the past learn from our mistakes but
one of the things that we learn from is
like you said if Anne Frank was tweeting
instead of writing in her diary I would
like to hope that we would have saved
millions of people yeah rather than
waiting until pretty much the end to
jump in and do something like don't wait
until another million people are dead
and we've seen a million beheadings and
a million other obscene acts against
humanity and then you go finally we're
gonna come in I'm like that's a million
lives that could have been saved and
maybe that's why some of those countries
are in shambles because we wait long and
then go in and a whole bunch of people
die and there's nobody to be rebuild
anything I think this is a fascinating
philosophical argument which they're not
having on the news at all which is why I
wanted to talk about it here what do you
guys think do we have to do something
and when I say we yeah America but does
the world have to do something are we
supposed to let it just just go to [ __ ]
what do we do about this let us know
what you think in the comments